Let's go next to our caller from the three
47 area code. Who's calling today from three,
four, seven, three 47 are you there? Are we
muted? Yes. There you are.
Yeah, it David.
Hey, who's this?
Um, I was Jordan.
Oh, Hey Jordan. What's going on?
Uh, I just had a quick question, right. So
I don't know. I'm, I'm still kind of young
and I was, I'm still deciding like where I
am on like the political spectrum and I kinda
wanted to know like what is like the less
like goals with immigration,
the left's goal?
Like, yeah, like the right, I know they always,
they kind of, they mostly want to keep illegal
immigrants out. But the last I always hear
about them trying to kind of loosening up
like border regulations. So kind of what is
like the end goal,
what would be an example of a border regulation
that the left wants to ease up?
So, um, I don't know. Like I've heard, um,
was the guy Adam Conover from Adams, everything.
He, um, he kinda had a problem with um, the,
by the border patrol that you can kind of
just stop random cars. He still was kind of
like infringement where rights. And I know
some people say that. I, I heard, I heard
a lot, like, I've heard a lot of, um, media
outlets say how elite, like, I can't make
my words together.
Let me help you out. Okay, let me, let me
help you out. Let me dis-aggregate a few things
for you cause I think there's maybe a little
bit of confusion. So, okay. First of all,
the issue of border patrol authority within,
I don't remember if it's 75 or a hundred miles
of a U S border that's controversial on the
left and right. There are constitutional conservatives
on the right who also love to go through those
checkpoints and, and um, you know, be obstinate
so to speak. So let's keep that out of it
cause that's not really border policy. So
I've not, there are, there are probably some
leftist who say we should have a truly open
border wherever anyone walks in and out and
can stay in the U S and can work legally or
whatever. That's not the predominant position
on the left. For the most part, what I would
consider to be the most prevalent left position
on immigration would be, uh, countries have
borders to the extent that we recognize that
nation States are a real thing.
Borders, uh, can be enforced and that's not
a problem. What we want to change is number
one, people who are already in the United
States illegally, uh, but are not committing
any kind of violent crime or whatever at this
point. The impracticality and immorality of
deporting them all is not a sensible position.
So we've got to figure out is there a path
to citizenship and what would it be? Number
two, DACA recipients, people who were kids
when they came to the U S illegally because
their parents brought them, they didn't do
anything wrong and now they're here. And to
the extent again, that they're not committing
crimes in the United States. They should be
allowed to stay, especially when for many
of them, the U S is the only country that
they've ever known. When we detain people
at the border, we need to detain them in a
way that's in line with what American values
and due process would be.
We don't put people in what are effectively
cages denying them, you know, even a toothbrush.
Those are the things that have to be changed
and that's where the left wants to do the
majority of, of immigration reform. There
are other things about should crossing the
border be a felony or more like a a a misdemeanor
or more like a civil infraction where you
get a ticket the first time versus the second
time. This is where the debate is really happening,
Jordan. It's not what it seems like you have
maybe a bit of a cartoonish impression of
where the debate is happening.
Yeah. I didn't really, cause I, I've never,
I don't really hear a lot of leftists really
state clearly what their opinion is. Okay.
I do hear them talk about the, the, the what
is it? The camps where the children being
separated. Yeah.
Well that's a, that's actually a good, it's
good to hear that from you because you're
making a very important point which is the
left can't simply say this stuff that the
right wants is wrong because then somebody
like you who's trying to figure out what are
the positions and where, where do I fall.
You just see the is saying everything the
right is doing is wrong, but you're not understanding
what position the left is articulating and
whether even if they're trying to do it clearly
they're failing because you didn't, it didn't
get to you, the message didn't get to you.
So I actually think it's interesting to hear
you say that and it's important.
All right.
Thank you David. Okay, Jordan, very much appreciate
the call. Hope to hear from you again.